paper straws that get all mushy in your
drink might not actually be as
environmentally friendly as you think
scientists over in Belgium say that
eco-friendly utensils are just as
harmful as the plastic ones and contain
potentially toxic forever chemicals oh
geez Sandra would you like to elaborate
I cannot stand
I cannot stand the paper straws they
were shoved on us and I think it's a
prime example of legislation before
thought so now we're all going to get
cancer from them is that what they're
telling us after we had to like is that
what the forever because they
disintegrated yep
you know we always end up shooting
ourselves in the foot you know like with
climate change we have to get an
electric car okay but to get an electric
car you know there's all kinds of
problems within burning and you know and
starting on fire and then if we get rid
of the battery there's an environmental
hazard and then we have to support China
and they're going to build more
coal-fired plants to make the uh lithium
and everything else for child labor and
Africa digging the Cobalt out for the
battery that's right but hey it's a good
idea climate change just like this we
don't think it through
not an issue for me you know my role men
should never and I mean ever
what do you do about a smoothie men
should never and I mean never drink a
smoothie
there's really nothing if you're like at
a sporting event and you get a chance
yeah it's not a masculine it's not a
masculine look but the smoothie I feel
like deserves
[Music]
exemption granted thank you and now
Jessie's can we also now that we're on
the exemptions I want to bring back foam
cups styrofoam cups are the greatest
enjoyment experience will be multiplied
maybe until they tell us how many beers
we can have in a day hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else